thank you all coming out today to listen
to i'm going to say and today i want to
tell you two stories okay two different
stories one is about science and one is
about scientists so both these stories
they go across the globe and they stand
all ages of human life okay and the
first is about malaria it's a it's a
story about three different species and
how they interact us humans mosquitoes
and parasite that causes malaria and
it's here with us for a long time and
it's a terrible disease that affects
people across the world but it's a
disease that we can cure and hopefully
we might see an eradicated in our
lifetime but there be any of fundamental
questions which have to be answered in
order to understand how to treat and
eradicate malaria and that's that's
where the science comes in okay but the
personal story I want to tell you is
what it is besides how I got to be a
scientist and what time to do okay
because just like the actual story of
malaria and how with what we know about
when there are being a scientist is kind
of a safe all the same the scientific
process is about starting with curiosity
about the world and wanting to
understand okay and then having a
problem or a questions you can't answer
and then you're you're provoked if
you're a scientist as opposed to a
politician or a liar just like so I'll
talk about problems in the console or
blame other people for them ok
scientists says okay I have a question I
can answer how can I describe that
question in a way where is a clearance
that's the heart that's the time it's
called making a hypothesis okay
formulating the question that you can
answer and then think okay how am I
going to do that and you have to go away
any better study and you're going to
learn and you got to build the skills
and the tools that we need to ask that
question and then you do experiments and
you try and address your exact questions
you've asked yourself and finally you're
going to apply your skills
alert analyze the results of your
experiment and answer your hypothesis
yes unlike and then that all starts over
again because every new question every
every question of the answer he provokes
new questions right and every question
is that an answer about malaria has
posed two new questions brought us
further in progress towards curing this
horrible truth so I just want to start
off a little bit of immerse myself so
how did I get into science so I come
from Hobart in Tasmania which is a
little island state of Australia ok less
than half a million people and it's
about as far from New Haven is possible
to get in the world ok this is a little
map from google map how you get there ok
if you actually type in google maps let
me tell you how to get there is like
drive here drive there and then take a
young sail across the city but that's
where i grew up i was born and raised
there and you know i was very lucky
because i had no parents who send me to
a good school I had everything I wanted
but I also thought that I would spend
the rest of my life in Tasmania and I
never go anywhere else except me for
holiday one time so what was I going to
do there well one of the interesting
things about test video is it's close to
Antarctica which is the continent where
the South Pole is covered in ice and
snow and his penguins north and so when
I was in grade 10 my pentagram in high
school we had this thing called job week
where everybody would off to be a lawyer
I'll be a politician to be a to be a
countess of my dad for a week and I
decided to go to the Australian
Antarctic division which happens to be
about half an hour out of Hobart and
that's where the boat comes back after
they've been studying in tactical 90
days I pocono ice penguin that sounds
adventurous so I went there what what
they SAT me down with my lab bench was a
jar of krill which are the little shrimp
that all the males
actually have a good cover best in the
summer now so they thought AHA is
director of my job is away every single
one of these krill this is actually from
Smithsonian's this joke here I had a
different one but I had a way every
single krill in that jar and they
thought that would take me a week but
you know pretty good so I think in two
days so then they gave you another job
and they said all right here is I got a
whole set of outlets and outlets are
little Fisher's ear bones each one month
of grain of sand and scientists who gave
him to me had about 100 of them she said
I needed to wreak at all okay so there I
was spending the rest of that week we
can along these tiny little going to see
and push him around wondering what
they're for now that Thursday she took
me down to the scanning electron
microscope and showed me one of these
things cut open and inside each one of
these little features here bones are
growth rings like trees tree trunks okay
from which you can actually age the fish
and a little a little lipo headband and
my hair things like wow do you mean to
tell me that these little grains of 10
on the Bushman arm squeezes for three
days hedin site every single one of them
is a life history of the fish which came
out of a ocean isle you know thousand
miles away and she's been painstakingly
extracting them and using the analytes
population density and i thought i would
be interested now the other light bulb
went off when i went back to school I
told everyone about these and everywhere
else in school eyes blush open what okay
counting drill or lids come on man and
then the second thing that went off in
my head was hmm you know I bet 99% of
everybody just thinks this is the most
boring thing in the world so it's great
to be smart and it's great to the other
issues but when you can find something
which almost everybody else would find
those dollars dishwater you can do it
all day and go home it's to be excited
about it evening you have found your
calling your life okay so that's when I
decided
no I here behind them okay and I went on
and that's what led me to go out of
state to go to college and then go out
of Australia and come all the way to
America if you might be HD and then
first in chicago and then don't get a
job in dallas and finally here in new
haven so if you don't take anything else
from this lecture here's what I want you
to learn okay science okay may not make
you rich will never make you famous
always but gives you a key if you enjoy
if you would at it stick with if you
will take you on a journey places you
never thought you go you want you won't
mind the right okay so now let me tell
you something that has nothing to do
with our time here but which both Hobart
Tasmania and New Haven Connecticut that
in common and that's nobody in new haven
or in Hobart suffers from malaria okay
but around the world almost 40% of the
human population lives in areas where
malaria is endemic okay and every year
hundreds of millions of people get sick
with it and almost a million people died
and nobody really knows how many because
most of the people that died our
children little kids under the age of
five so it's a terrible disease that we
should fight to prevent and we don't
know how many people get sick of malaria
but we know that we have been getting
sick with malaria as long as we have
been around because it's found Egyptian
mummies it's been written about by the
ancient Chinese and the ancient Greeks
and the word malaria comes from italian
phrase means bad air because in romans
and everyone else after that thought
that actually came from the current
smelly fumes in swamps and mushrooms
where host from area was occurring and
thousands of human history a thousand
years most of human history there really
wasn't any cure for malaria any except
to get away from it and that's what most
people did okay and even into the 19th
century where you know people came to
learn about science and Louis Pasteur is
the first time you came up the idea to
diseases of course for me caused by
germs and they made
you know Steve clean our food and good
sanitation we can prevent disease that
was really interesting but still no one
knew what caused the lyric okay so the
first guy to figure that out was french
guy called Alphonse look around and he
thought huh there's this dude called
Louis Pasteur has this hypothesis that
disease caused by germs so I'm going to
go and look in the blood of my patients
who have Blair so when you get malaria
what it's like is having this horrible
fever with delirium and lasts for hours
and then it repeats every couple of days
this is the symptoms of malaria so he
looked with malaria patients and he
looked under a microscope at SL so you
know that in your body your whole body
is made up of trillions of little units
called self inside each cell is a
different you know set of machines the
molecular level that can do all things
they need to do muscle cells and brain
cells inside your blood you could blood
cells in the blood cells job the red
blood cells is to transport or oxygen
around your body debris well inside the
red blood cells mr. love Graham saw
someone shouldn't be there some other
little cells and he drew a picture of it
these are lots of other pictures you
drew over here okay and he realized he'd
found a micro a single cell organism
okay which is the malaria parasite so
that was really interesting and that
moves the question the first question
like what causes malaria is a
single-celled parasite its lives out
loud and eats up all of the insides of
our red blood cells okay and then every
couple of days after he's finished up
one cell and burst out to go another
that's when you get fever well the
problem was i running thought okay
there's one question answer but opposes
another how do we get malaria and he
went back to italy and you know whenever
the swamps and look at the bar and you
look at the border you know air and he
couldn't find any of these things anyway
so he thought whom what else do sports
have except mud water and foul air well
they've got a lot of mosquitoes so he
hypothesized that malaria could be
transmitted
mosquitoes well as one thing to
hypothesize and then you have to do
experiments you have to prove that by
pollicis it was actually another by
british scientists called Ronald Ross
who then was using in their time with
Earl's had malaria and he looked inside
the bodies of mosquitoes were
transmitting malaria found little cysts
which where malaria parasites in their
bodies so Ronald Ross is a guy who
actually proved that malaria transmitted
by mosquitoes and today actually on the
right hand side i'm showing you from us
from a paper in the literature actually
malaria parasites which have been
genetically engineered to express a
project called green fluorescent protein
and that makes it easy for them to count
to count them under microscope and so
that's used routinely now studies of
malaria transmission Skeeter so for this
both long Ross and once lever run one in
the logo price which is like the Olympic
gold medal of science okay and Ronald
rows one and 1902 and and fossil around
wanted him non MSM still a long time ago
right but now we know that malaria is
parasitic disease it's transmitted
between people by mosquitoes so the
mosquito is not what causes malaria but
it transmits it and in that case it's
called a vector and infectious diseases
like this have called vector-borne
diseases and the life cycle is very
complicated so we don't need to that's
terrible but the point is there are
three different organisms involved
mosquito the malaria parasite and human
and there are when we talk in science
about different organisms we give them
scientific names first agenus and then
the species it's like giving you
so it turns out they're not all
mosquitoes transmit malaria only certain
the genes-- for mosquitoes Napoles jenis
okay and there are lots of species of
anopheles mosquitoes and malaria
parasites all belong to word jenis
called Plasmodium and there are hundreds
of species of malaria parasites it all
affects different birds and mammals and
reptiles and all sorts of mammals that
each each malaria species only affects
one vertebra closed like a specific
species of bird or a specific you know
rat or power or person and there are
five known species that transmit malaria
from people to their fire features a
funeral there but only one of them
called Plasmodium falciparum is really
responsible for 97 deaths and second one
for plasmodium vivax is responsible for
the others so the important thing to
note is that since the malaria parasite
each species it only affects one other
vertebrate species so plasmodium
falciparum only infects humans that's
different from other things you might
hear about that you get from mosquitoes
like West Nile virus or he's done equine
encephalitis bars because these can also
be passed by mosquitoes other species
like horses or birds but because malaria
only traffics between the mosquito
people if you cure all people of malaria
there will be nowhere for the mosquitoes
to get malaria themselves and then
there'll be nowhere for people to get
there from ski toes and you will
eradicate the disease and that's exactly
what's happened here the United States
as well as Europe Russia happen after
world war two and it can happen
worldwide it's just a lot more difficult
in the tropics but it definitely is
achieved so you might think okay we
solved that problem is already lose your
phone sick people who have malaria and
cure the right we get the medicine we
have this it's treatable disease and it
should be pretty easy to find a listing
people because they should be rolling
around you know these are cute fever
every couple of days right well not so
easy because it turns out that most
people who live after if you're an adult
you live in a tellurian tenant region
Africa you have malaria but you don't
get sick now why is that why don't
people get sick even when when when they
get infected something that's because we
have immune system before we came up
with medicine okay or anything else we
have our own bodies as our first line of
defense and we have a special type of
immunity that's called adaptive immunity
so when you get sick you have certain
cells in your blood these are not the
red blood cells these are white blood
cells okay they're called lymphocytes
and they can respond to the infection
and try to kill whatever to make music
and sometimes they're successful and
eventually you get better right with
even without medicine you just rest and
you know your your immune system can
help you you'll get better and the thing
is your adaptive immune system learns so
the next time you can see you have cells
other lymphocytes in your body that
remember what you've got secret the last
time and they have they have the
molecular medicine inside them to treat
that infection so the next time you get
sick it's not as bad okay and you
remember and this remember you can last
few years so if you live past the age of
five in sub-saharan Africa you've
already had malaria are about 20 30
times probably okay and you have a suite
of what's called Angie points any
mornings that are molecules proteins
that come out of your B lymphocytes ok
we are white blood cells and protect you
from malaria now thing with being
anybody's that people make to malaria is
that don't necessarily cure I you don't
necessarily kill all the malaria
parasites you just keep it at a lower
level and then you can be a carrier so
mosquito might bite you would still pick
up parasites but you don't ever get city
okay but but when children get bitten by
mosquito they haven't got those anyways
and that's why most people die true so
the adaptive immune system that was
actually figured out by a lot of people
around the same time as people were
discovering malaria
but it took another 50 years to
understand really how it works in
molecular level because he do you think
about it's not just malaria that makes
you sick as there's all sorts of
thousands and thousands you know viruses
and other bacteria and how could you as
a baby you know have all the molecules
you need your body to protect yourself
against everything you might meet in
your life right you'd have to have
nothing in your body but white blood
cells well there's a way around them a
really clever way and to know that you
need to know that in every cell of our
body we have DNA in DNA my tomato that's
that's like our genetic code is like a
set of instructions and that DNA gets
turned into proteins and proteins are
you know what you're supposed to eat a
lot of if you're on South Beach diet and
it's actually all the things that your
body makes out of DNA okay and then do
the work to the enzymes their tissue to
make your muscles and these are the
molecules which do mostly work in your
body so there is a specialist kind of
protein okay Colin anybody that can
protect you from disease but how can you
have enough anyway there is not enough
DNA in your cell to courage all the NY
trip to meet me so 50 years later a
couple guys came up with an answer to
that which is that you and all mammals
it turns out have a special way to
reprogram ourselves okay to very own
genetic code now normally you don't want
to change your code we go to all sorts
of trouble all organisms to protect our
DNA and copy it exactly from one
generation of the next on and on you
know without any errors but we have
special sets of proteins which are
designed to randomize parts of our DNA
that code for any words now you did that
what happened if you made it anybody
that attacked your own body right you'd
have an autoimmune disease and that will
be very nicely if you started to hack
your employee so how do you prevent that
and this is what's called the clonal
selection hypothesis so it turned and
this is a hypothesis people came up with
before they really knew
about these proteins and DNA and how it
all done okay and their two guys who
came up so frankly trauma Burnett
another Aussie okay and he was a
Melbourne and he came up the idea what
if you had these white blood cells which
are formed in the bone marrow and during
that time okay we have special mechanism
for randomizing the DNA and a certain
part of that molecule so that you could
make a kind of library isn't it kind of
coded molecular library from everything
we could possibly need and every cell
every feeling as I got a different quote
okay and then it would leave and go to
your blood and it wouldn't do anything
unless along came a molecule or a
bacteria that happened to code code for
that anybody that it could reactivate
and then that's the sin Excel would get
amplified and you would respond to
whatever you meant whatever dangerous
bug you meant and that's a good idea
okay but again how do you prevent
yourself from taking your own body well
that was what Peter Medawar is british
scientist kind of business that you must
have some mechanism to self-tolerance so
why are your blood cells being made in
the bone marrow okay they test the
expression of their proteins all these
different random proteins if any of
those proteins actually bind to another
human protein or then exhale get killed
so you first of all screen out all of
the molecules in your library that would
react with your own proteins and those
that survive we need to circulate in
your blood and just wait until they're
activated by an infection then they're
amplified they respond and then they're
kept kept as a memory cell for the next
time you get infected so that was a
clonal selection hypothesis and and it
turns out to be true and for that
especially
faceted that be true people more happy
that it's false so the following burnett
and been a mad about they shared the
nobel prize in 1964 this now that's
interesting idea but to understand how
it really works what you need to know
the molecular structure of these
anyone's because it's the molecular
structure of a protein shake the atomic
level that tell you how actually does
its work and for that you need to know
some physics so you all been sitting
here thinking I can just go to do med
school is open is look at the slides
like those muscle cells and electrical
stuff what am I looking at sunflower
check it out there why do I have to sit
down old Kurt Zillman land quantum
mechanics for goodness sake here's one
okay if you want to know the structure
the atomic structure of a protein you
have to be able to crystallize okay and
that's like making a salt crystal or an
ice jam it's on your on a ring okay this
is a special type of matter type of
matter which all the molecules are
arranged in particular like all these
chairs one after the other row upon row
from all three dimensions and if you
have occurred in the crystal turns out
you can crystallize all about anything
these are all crystals I grew in the
last five years okay well there's
something special about a crystal okay
it can reflect you see this beautiful
little crystal here it's reflecting like
okay it's reflecting it because of the
light is reflected off the surface
became auto Christopher right just like
a mirror but inside the crystal and all
the atoms inside the crystal can also
reflect light but not just regular life
a special pipe water for x-rays okay so
as you know like radio waves microwaves
x-rays and gamma rays which are
producing bubbles in a cloud chamber up
front those are all types of electro
radiation waves which have an
oscillation and when waves bounce off
anything they bounce off as little
skiers they go everything okay spherical
waves come out but those waves can
interfere with one another if you drop
two rocks in a pond you'll see little
ripples going out and when those ripples
intersect you'll see pics you'll see
troughs where those waves combined okay
well at the atomic layer if you have x
rays which are very very high frequency
waves okay and they oscillate on the
same scale as atoms inside these protein
crystals then all those x-rays gets
scattered up all those happens and it's
the particular places where all the
atoms are in regular Rose distance and
angle that's right those x-rays will
interfere make a big peak which you can
measure and if you can measure all those
that information okay then using
mathematics you can calculate what is
the structure of atoms that gave rise to
the pen and that's called x-ray for
celebrity so that's the physics you need
to learn to understand how we can look
at molecules on a tumblr be they be they
you know drives can be those proteins
RNA anything so you see a molecule can
get stacked two little boxes inside a
crystal okay and when they all line up
then they can all scatter x rays at
certain points in space which we can
measure now to make those x-rays you
need a big machine okay we have a
machine over here in kimchi department
that can make x-rays but most people
today go and use the particle
accelerator okay that's a big green
which subatomic particles are flung
around at relativistic speeds clusen
speed of life and out the side come very
powerful x-rays so I'd rather draw that
not to scale a little ring really like
hundreds of meters across okay and then
you sit at the end of that on the
tangent to that thing and you put your
little crystal in a position where it
gets hit by the x-rays and outcomes in a
fraction pattern that's what's shown up
a top right corner of the slide all
these little spots those are all x rays
which is being diffracted from all the
proteins that are in the crystal when
they get refracted a special places and
then nine of math and physics in the
news computer you can calculate where
all the electrons were became rights to
their patterns and the computer you can
build a model of protein now that was
pretty hard to do back in the fifties
when the farmer had about came up with
their final selection responses but a
little while later in the 70s it came
possible and this is the structure of an
intact anyone on the first ever ok by a
couple of German Gaius October and on
Stephen Harper and you see that what's
important about this molecule is it's
very flexible okay it looks like a wire
and the different parts of is why can
move around and the bit of protein which
gets randomized inside your B
lymphocytes it's like at the end of this
one so you have like a guy [ __ ] and
lobster biomolecule molecule okay and
each lovely has a different set of
clamps on it okay you can grab Hall of a
different molecule and you can have
billions and trillions of different
different antibodies each with a
different set of clamps okay and this is
what's produced so that they may combine
all sorts of different different things
different proteins bacteria viruses and
all of these things are circulating your
body now I said that there were two
stories here with a scientific story a
personal story so the personal story is
okay this is about a year after I was
born okay so I was feeling that bees and
all this was going on okay but it was
done by he's guy Robert goober okay and
not a fellow professor dies in harvard
professor dies another guy i used to
work for back and else and all the while
I was like chopping up odorless okay
thinking about fish down in Antarctica
row at Hoover enhanced eyes off of
peeking
rise of their own in solving the
structure of important moment not
annually but the special a special
molecule quarter photosynthetic reaction
center that's the protein inside all
planets and all five simple organisms it
turns ymg into chemical energy very
important project well after that harms
got a job in Dallas moved out there and
that's where i went to work for him
later on now back to the science of
malaria so we have anyones for all sorts
of teams and anyone who lives in
malaria-endemic area topics they get any
boys okay then protects it from malaria
so one of people stupid see okay because
if anybody so good and now music seems
so good why do I was doin secrets
because evolution just as we could adapt
and we have any buddies can adapt to
respond to different infections well the
things that make a sick can adapt as
well and the malaria parasite turns out
is be the kind of Michael Jackson of
adapt adaptation okay in the rock and
roll world of infectious disease because
this is not like a virus which had one
protein and you can have an end by that
protein drink at Sycamore they have
hundreds of products on his lips and
they change them all the time right so
they're like a like a combination lock
that's always changing so you always
need to be updating your anybody
repertoire and even someone who lives in
a malaria endemic region they go to the
city for ten years you know you get a
job and they come back to the boat they
can get sick get because the malaria
parasites have a definite time the baby
insisted passage and that's a big
problem because once we knew that we had
anybody's you will realize until you're
back in the 90 that if you could have
what's called the anti je ne Jim is
whatever anybody minds to and if you
give someone an antigenic right for a
bacteria or virus okay just that then
they'll make those anybody without
getting seed and then when that when
that bug that virus that bacteria comes
along they'll already have the
anyone know what that's called it's
called vaccination that's right okay and
is one of the most successful you know
medical interventions in the world okay
save hundreds of millions of lives and
most important things you should all get
two shots right for diseases that can
make you very sick Aziz's which we don't
even know about anymore we've forgotten
what they're like because they like
measles or pertussis okay it's used to
make people very sick okay no maybe 50
years ago and today I mean anybody knows
within what they're like like why should
I go get a vaccine why should I go get
my shot I'm no one to stick around here
well that's why these diseases are
coming back because people don't get
vaccinated and then so they can get
diseases again when people come here
knowing my great country and have that
disease in sitting in sofa tosses
whooping cough is on the rise in United
States and measles is on the rise in
Europe okay so it's really important to
get your shots and get back cement the
single most effective tool you have to
pay disease better than medicine a
prevention is better than cure and for a
long time people were trying to make a
vaccine against Blair right we know that
that with the people who live in malaria
endemic countries they have egg whites
and they're protected so why can't we
just find that magic molecule okay and
for a long time he will look to these
polymers and they looked at the projects
that we're on the parasite and they look
at the proteins that one should required
for the parasite to infect our red blood
cells and then they tried to make
vaccines based on that and nothing
worked why not well because Blair
parasite has really
way of evading our immune system it's
why he hides hides inside our own selves
so while I was digesting your red blood
cells it's inside the red cluster so
your antibodies are all circulating out
of your blood they don't see it and
before that it goes to the liver right
hi sis are you living so your immune
system doesn't see it so when does your
immune system see the malaria parasite
when can you actually stop it fiction
only in a few minutes when you've been
bitten by a mosquito and the parasites
are being injected into you buy them in
the disputer survivor and they have to
go through your bloodstream and get to
the liver at that stage is called the XO
electrics with receding stage so it's
not in any self it's got to go through
your body and it's exposed to your
immune system so how does it evade your
immune system then well as a clever
probe away okay millet Plasmodium
parasite makes a protein on the surface
is called the circumpolar so I project
on that CSP for sure see this guy korsak
see Jessa people learn at times always
go idea to come up the short names so
the CSP protein was discovered and
cloned in 994 okay and it turns out that
this protein is all over the malaria
parasite when it comes in your watch I
mean it's coded is a micron thick you
can see it unlike my prospects and what
this protein is more it's essential for
the gliding motility so when this entire
site comes into your body malaria
parasite enters your body it's got to
move and it moves like a snake wriggling
a rock through your cells and as it
moves okay it's covered in this slimy
protein college circumscribe as I
protein CSP which slides along from its
front of fact okay and he's left in its
wake like a like
stick on the water okay and you can see
it if you put kind of malaria parasite
of last slide they go round and round
and round like a like a NASCAR yeah
making tracks on a glass slide leaving
this slime like a snail circumscribes
like project so what happens not only is
this party really important with include
but it's a deeper because they leave a
whole bunch of this protein in your body
and if you're going to make anybody's to
something your body's like oh this is
not mine isn't the micro team but I'm
going to make an anyone hears that so
the dominant any way that you develop to
Alaric outside is anybody's to the
certain spot as I project so what's the
problem with that the problem is that
the circumscribed coding doesn't stay on
it [ __ ] is slimy wait so your label
easily or anyways just as the malaria
parasite is wriggling along there
anybodys come and bind the CSD protein
and then off go somewhere packs are
shared to the protein okay like a snake
sheds its skin and goes with your liver
and you get it but once they load that
once we understood that I'm stood at the
molecular level how we make antibodies
against against malaria proteins and how
the malaria parasite evade our immune
system then scientists could look at the
structure of this protein and they could
design a new handkerchief okay and they
came up with the idea okay what if
instead of trying to make whatever
instead of trying to make and anybody
can pull the power of the proteins that
the malaria parasite has
the blood and people try to make all
those anybody's all those vaccines
against those proteins of the never made
it back sequels worth being instead
let's just deliberately try make a
vaccine again this project
circumspection ready which is only
around for a few minutes when this
parasite eventually came to watch and it
turns out that was a good idea okay but
there's a problem this product is not
very computer Jennifer now when I make a
vaccine I want to vaccinate your
gangster disease first of all I have to
give you that protein and you have to
make anyone gangster even though you're
like pick it does out it's not always so
easy to trick your immune system to make
any any what you want so you have to
respond and it turns out the second
score as I protein when you make it as
protein away from the Larry parasite
it's not very energetic so it was Victor
and ruthless about and several hours you
came up with idea of using the second
spar as I protein okay but was another
guy joke on okay at a company called
glaxosmithkline you came up with a
clever idea of using the circuits are as
I predict to another protein hepatitis B
3 so we also get vaccinated against
viral hepatitis B okay very important to
get that vaccine and it turns out that
the vaccine the collects a stiff fine
debate again except times B was a really
good vaccine so using genetic
engineering they could make a chimera of
protein the Chimera comes from an
ancient Greek myth gets animal three
animals used together so we can make hi
Mary proteins but we join puttering
another in the lab today engineering and
then we could express and make that
project so what they what they did they
took the circuit as far as I've heard it
from
parasite they used it to a piece of epic
itís be protein is used to vaccinate
against and Cosby and they made a
vaccine which protects you against both
hepatitis B and the malaria and it's a
bit better malaria vaccine that any
malaria vaccines ever being before and
then the vaccine on the right hand side
show you the 20 years or so took to get
where we are now which is a visit the
first-ever vaccine that's in phase 3
clinical trials and children in Africa
and it's by no means one hundred percent
effective okay if you go and get your
heavy shot you go get your polio shot
Oreo measles mumps rubella shot you're
pretty much cutting 99.99 per second
malaria vaccine thirty percent effective
so there's a long way to go a whole new
generation of vaccines need to be
developed but this is the first ever
which is showing efficacy in clinical
trials and that's from a hundred years
of research understanding the molecular
basis of their now I'd like to take
credit for that but I didn't have
anything to do with that okay but that
is to show you how questions these
answers which leads to new questions and
that's how we can make programs to fight
a deadly disease which is effective
humanity 4,000 years but there's
something missing in this equation
that's mosquito because for all the
research that we do molera and drugs and
vaccines that generally most effective
cost effective strategy to prevent
malaria transmission is to prevent you
getting bitten by mosquitoes it's two
ways to do that that are really affected
the cheapest most effective way right
now is to give people an insecticide
treated better ok so the skiers like the
fight at night asleep
so if you sleep under a bed net then
they can't get you and watch more if you
pregnate that bed net with set-asides
the mosquitoes that come to try and bite
you dot and then it turns out that it is
probably where that is insecticide so it
lasts very long they're chemicals and
chemicals kind of go off of this month
but using chemistry and people figured
out how to impregnate their nets with
chemicals which life struck for five
years they busted a dollar each and now
the World Health Organization and the
Bill Gates and melinda dillon gates
foundation and spent hundreds of
millions of dollars they distributing
these pants strata okay and they're as
effective in case control trial
including regional say they're as
effective as the back seats in affected
alone reducing vaccine that are reducing
disease transmission so for dollar pulp
that's a pretty good that's pretty good
dealing now how we did it in america is
DDT okay so we just kill mosquitoes by
spreading right now in dallas glad I'm
up hearing you have it now because a lot
of West Nile virus down in Dallas is
some okay and so they drive around in
the truck and they follow insecticide
everywhere John killed in school and
when back in the 50s we wanted to
eradicate malaria from Russia and
southern Europe the United States DDT
was a miracle insecticide it's very was
very safe from people okay but deadly
for mosquitoes and it was used to
literally get rid of the mosquitoes and
break the transmission sign
unfortunately DDT is a has a problem a
big environmental problem cuz out that
it's a it's a very hazardous books and
we all
many bird species including water you go
girl from the bald eagle go extinct the
United States so DDT's band making we
developed countries but it's still used
in Africa today because it's one of the
most cost effective methods of six
cyclotron but it was certainly be good
it would come up with new insecticides
other ways to to kill mosquitoes involve
using DDT so the major insecticide which
is used today it's on your bed nets it's
called a pyrethroid it actually comes
from pyrethrins which is actually a
chemical in flowers for presenters and
so it's a biologically safe and
effective insecticide and it's in most
of the cans of bug spray that you
probably have bottom shelf well there's
a problem with that probably settings
mosquitoes just like malaria parasites
they can adapt that's what evolution is
evolution is constant adaptation change
so just as we can adapt okay to
infections by bacteria viruses anything
else so malaria parasites could adapt
where I mean system to continue to
affect us and mosquitoes can adapt they
can adapt to insecticides right by
mutations in the proteins of those
chemicals target in their bodies and
today in Africa large sections of a
population of mosquitoes are resistant
to pyrethroids and DDT so what are we to
do about that well there's a lot of
research going on to try and find new
insecticides and new ways to kill
mosquitoes but one of the things I want
to tell you about is the immune system
of them skin so it turns out and this
was very surprised many times work for
Christopher dembele's actually I work on
project in the mosquito that actually
fight malaria
so so you think that you know for a long
time or things that malaria is
transmitted by mosquitoes and mosquitoes
don't really they don't really mind you
know it doesn't make them sick but it
turns out the mosquitoes don't like
getting malaria are much more than we do
and they they fight it they have an
immune system now insects such as
mosquitoes they're different for all of
us they don't have adaptive immune
system they can't reprogram their their
DNA to make a new model and that I'm
lead to because they don't really live
long enough to do that mosquito lives
for a few weeks at most right and lace
thousands of eggs in that time only the
females on a female's body so the mouse
gets on getting water in each of life so
they can lay lots of eggs do they do
that and died a few weeks then that done
their job so insects don't have adaptive
immunity but they do have another kind
of immunity court in a community and we
also have that ignition because it takes
a little time for you to make an angle
if you get infected with a bug like fire
call it called every year it's a new
version okay then you get a little sick
and it takes you about a week or a
couple of days you know to kind of get
better if you already have some
anybody's that's great but have you done
it can take you a week to make you angry
cell which is selected an amp on your
boy and if that's all you had okay you'd
be dead pretty quickly from some nasty
safety conviction your blood it would
amplify and take over your body long
before you had time taking anybody so
you have a whole bunch of innate immune
responses to protect you by generally
protecting against all my girls they
recognize molecules that are common to
all bacteria are common all viruses and
it turns out that the innate immune
system okay was also something that just
again to be studied in the 70s and the
80s okay and in fact it was a professor
immunology here yet Charlie Janeway who
first hypothesized that there must exist
like for us to have this
we do that we would have to have
proteins in our bodies that were
pattern-recognition receptors not
anybody's not specific to a single
module but they recognize a general
possible something that all bacteria
such as the chemicals that the molecules
that all bacteria have on their cell
walls because we ourselves don't have
cell walls or bacteria have watering
their selves nose walls have specific
chemical components well round 9 95
lodged in my PhD there was a French
scientist okay called O'Toole's Hoffman
who was studying for summer and he
discovered that there was a particular
gene or Paul and if you knocked out his
gene or his wife suddenly died upon this
that's good for thumbs so it seemed like
this gene was essential for them to
protect against infection and when he
published his okay Charlie's anyway he
also I got a brisk walk eat except
Western okay they went and looked at the
sequences they had at that time the
human genome hadn't even been sequenced
but it's like well maybe there's a
similar molecule human comes out there
is and we actually have a suite of these
proteins they call toll like receptors
okay and they protect us from infection
when they become a very important part
of even logical research unfortunately
Charlie a waiting with to see it last
year just awful and bridgeport look but
there are no go prize for the discovery
of these tolerances so we share actually
a history with insects okay not of
adaptive immunity what in the nativity
now back to malaria as I say the
mosquito also wants to protect itself
another infection so it turns out the
mosquitoes they make proteins that also
do their blood and wear when they drink
a blood meal from us take a bite the
parasites want to go into their body and
then they want to go
across them gut and make little sisters
insist inside their body and in that
short space of time in a few hours in
between when they cross the bigger and
when they're going to make these cysts
they are susceptible to attack by the
proteins that are in the skills planet
so I went to Dallas after I got my PhD
and I went to work Freddy dodge hunter
and I knew a bit of physics in a bit of
a karmic proteins it's a protein
crystallography and these are the
structured molecular level of those
credit crystals I shown you slide a
couple of slides before and by taking
the suit Ron and diffracting x-rays of
the other than doing calculations we can
understand the structure of these
proteins and these protein in particular
is one over here is called it's called
tip one it's called that's there's a
thigh oster containing protein one
because it has incited a special
chemical bond for the thigh oster right
and that's a reactive reactive molecule
chemical bond that can react with the
surface of the malaria parasite and bind
that tip one protein to the parasite
that's like a molecular targeting suit
okay it's like a laser guided munition
this molecule circulates in the blood
waiting for infection okay and it's
regulated to regulated by set of other
molecules okay to other parties I solved
the structure off they also have
activism I'm not going to tell you the
full name because they'll all right
remember in biology a kind of short
names for things okay so when it's
called elrom one and one the others
called AP Owain see those proteins that
form a complex themselves and then and
they may form a complex with the thigh
oster containing protein and this whole
commish ways it's like a loaded pistol
waiting for an infection and when
mosquito gets infected okay the tech one
party gets recruited to that side of
infection and released exactly where
that chemical bond the thioester bond
can react with the surface of the miller
parasite and stick the tape one onto
that surface and it is this like a
targeting signal coming call in an air
strike on kill this guy and it turns out
that now I studying different alleles in
this project so mosquito is canted act
they can't change their DNA during our
lifetime to come with new models but
they can have enormous genetic diversity
in their population so you can imagine
how many mosquitoes there are in Africa
burns 1 billion solvent they can all
have different different genes have
different sequences for the same thing
gene that's cool those are called
alleles okay so just like we have
different blood types a B and O we all
text because we have different versions
of the same protein okay and we
recognize that's outlawed and not
somebody else's and it's important to
know that if you do a blood transplant
and we have another set of molecules
called the major histocompatibility
complex that's also telling us what is
our self we have hundreds of alleles in
this truth and those were also
hypothesized okay bye this is the idea
of self-tolerance the pee the bed of our
first came up with how can we protect
ourselves from ourselves right so
there's another Destin example of one of
the most diverse alleles entire human
general major histocompatibility complex
well mosquitoes since they can't
engineer their own DNA in a lifetime
they can have many different alleles at
FG and here are five of them okay and
here is a bunch of letters which code
for amino acids which are in this
protein and different mosquitoes which
you can sample and study them and
extract their DNA and analyze it from
all over Africa okay have different
classes of these alleles and there are
two major classes okay one is called tip
1s there stands the susceptible mosquito
and one is tip 10 and that's been
or resistant mosquito because these two
different mosquitoes one of them can get
infected by the road to malaria parasite
which people study in the lab the one I
show you with the green question protein
so that's what times do you say the lab
is it's a lot more competitive state
human malaria and mosquito in the lab if
you don't to get bitten right whereas
that tap on s the susceptible cos they
do get infected so there's two different
mosquitoes which have this one gene with
two different our ills one gets infected
now that doesn't get infected so we can
use protein crystallography they look at
the structure of these two proteins and
compare them and look specifically where
the where the molecules are different
and that can tell us something that how
they how they function different and in
particular okay what I'm showing here is
that when you look the molecular
structure all the files containing 31
and you look at where these alleles are
different they're over not even said I
did okay but they're different in
specific regions and those specific
regions are on Luke's the party that are
right next to this virus okay which is
why we think they're important to the
function of the protein and then in the
lab we can check that these proteins
really actually have a different
reactivity okay so we can look at the
reactivity of the thioester which is in
the tip one i won't i won't try to
explain what this graph is a graph
measuring the hydrolysis of the fire a
trip but what is important is that the
our protein which is on the right stands
for resisted the our protein is more
stable than the S project we can measure
quantitatively a difference in the
reactivity of this thioester bond which
is related to differences in
their amino acid composition and these
are different alleles which come from
mosquitoes they're different parts of
Africa okay and then other researchers
have gone and looked in the field okay
all across Africa in times of the year
in Cameroon and garner bikini faso a
mile okay and picked dozens of
mosquitoes and sequence their genes and
they discovered that indeed these
alleles are present in mosquitoes
throughout Africa and they're different
so the skeeters in Tanzania even at the
same species are different from the same
mosquito species in Ghana and it turns
out that if you take a malaria parasite
from one African country like Cameroon
and then you put that into a mosquito
from Tanzania at mosquito working and
pick and you take malaria parasites from
10 min put them into a mosquito from
Cameroon Skeeter work in figure so the
malaria parasite is having to adapt not
only to our own immune system but to the
mosquitoes immune system constantly and
if we understand more about the
mosquitoes immune system we may
understand why some skaters are more
likely to transmit malaria that could be
important if you only have limited
resources and how you're going to use
those resources to target the mosquitoes
which are most dangerous and in
particular if you look at this graph
what it's showing is that the are the s
don't look at the s and amateur up here
to talk because those are the actual
different molecular form from skier
there's a little colored boxes here the
blue stands for yes that's the SG for
the susceptible mosquitoes and then the
green is actually encoding for the r
gene the resistant gene which are the
same two proteins that i showed you this
molecular structure so you can see that
the RG has been swept to fixation in a
specific molecular form of them skewers
and then if you look at those mosquitoes
and test their ability to get infected
with the human malaria parasite there's
a statistically significant difference
in the level of infection between two
sets of mosquitoes that differ only in
one copy of this allele so that shows
that this just like acid just like
humans who have acquired immunity to
malaria mosquitoes are adapting to their
environment across Africa they may not
necessarily be selected for their
resistance to plasmodium they may be
being selected to fight another
infection some other bacteria some other
buyers some other pilots but that
selection leads them to have a different
level of infection for malaria so
there's a lot of work to do we need to
develop new vaccines we need to develop
new drugs and we need to understand
better how malaria is transmitted by
mosquitoes but what I want to tell you
end on is telling you that for all this
work and all this study there's so much
more to do okay so much for you kids to
do right because we need new vaccines
and no one knows how to make them okay
and it's not just valaria that makes
people see this slide showing you half a
dozen other insects across the world
that you know make a lot of people sick
from a lot of different diseases we
don't know much less about how they are
transmitted and how we can fight them so
there's a lot of work to do to continue
to learn and understand and local level
how to fight disease and finally i
showed you the history of famous people
who had studied science and now i'm
getting my own chance to do my own
research but i don't do it alone okay no
one doesn't like it takes a lot of
people working together to just research
so this is Professor Dyson hunter who I
worked with the supposed off when I also
worked with another post doc porch on me
and lady called yoga
helping in doing my research gasps and
now that I'm here in New Haven I have a
bunch of young people in my lab who are
helping me like and I want to thank
being and money and Shankar's
undergraduate student is waiting for
something ok and help to actually make
the crystal make the structure of the
tip 1s protein that I showed you just a
few slides ago and it takes a lot of
feet so it takes a lot of people and it
also takes collaboration not just in a
lab but across the world so we
collaborate with ok dr. Elaine alleged
shooter she's actually bullied
max-planck-institut reinvention biology
ok and also Stephanie London who is a
French researcher at the University of
Strasbourg the same department where
jules hoffman is the director ok and
finally it takes a lot of money ok and
this is always a problem ok because no
one wants to spend money on anything
these days ok but it's really important
that we have federal funding for our
research ok and I've been funded by the
national institute of allergy and fixes
diseases and attributes of health we
also have private sources of funding and
also sources of funding from from the
French government ok and all of this is
required to make science possible so if
you have any questions I'd be delighted
than answer them and i hope you enjoyed
yourselves and or hope that
the updates will stick with songs
because it's a lot of